this virus has stolen so much and many
who've lost loved ones haven't even been
able to say goodbye
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke to a psychologist and a man who
lost his mother to the coronavirus
she joins us live in the studio now with
more madison yes while our emotions are
not something we often publicly discuss
during time of isolation due to the
cova-19 pandemic
it's important we find a way to cope
i've seen people continue to use drugs
even more than they did before
feel isolated i see people losing family
members and friends
and the grief part that you mentioned is
about a loss of how life used to be
a reality for many this past year as
covet 19 has taken over
our lives whether you know someone that
has had it or you've experienced it
yourself
the lack of normalcy we have endured for
the past 10 months would make anyone
feel
out of control dr solomon says lately
the amount of drug use
she has seen at her recovery center has
been extremely high
a lot of people coming to me because
they have substance abuse issues
that has gotten so out of hand because
they're just home all the time and so
there's no real delineation between work
time and home time
patrick casal a health insurance broker
in las vegas recently just lost his
mother to the deadly virus
he says the hardest part was not being
able to be with her when she took her
last breath
it's the hardest thing i've ever had to
do in my life not to say goodbye to my
mother i hold her
i tell her i love her i can't believe
how many people i actually know
that either had coveted or passed away
from covid dr
solomon says normalcy and connectiveness
is key when coping with this kind of
grief
whatever makes you feel normal so trying
to figure out how you can do certain
activities whether they're exercise
connecting with friends over zoom over
face time however you can feel connected
to family and friends
is so important right now as for casal
in march he plans on having a ceremony
in his mother's honor
and plans to spread her ashes in her
home state of new york
now if you or you know someone currently
having a hard time adjusting to the
changes
brought on by the pandemic you're not
alone and there are resources to help
the national suicide prevention line is
up on your screen
reporting in studio madison kimbrough 8
news now